ja bei erg der Junge ist eine Menge
los da überschlagen sich ja die
Ereignisse K1 flir und auch bushido ist
am Start und zwar Bushido mit einem
eigenen wmsong darüber wollen wir mit
ihm reden und auch ihr könnt ihm wieder
Fragen
stellen die wir ihm dann als Video am
besten vorspielen aber auch in den
Kommentaren sind Fragen möglich
allerdings sind da die Chancen weil so
unglaublich viele sind und wir eventuell
nicht dazu kommen werden nicht so hoch
also am besten videofragen und kreative
videofragen also nicht Bushido wie bist
du zu deinem Namen gekommen da wird er
wahrscheinlich noch mal sagen guck dir
den Film an liest das Buch also
disgefahr bei solchen Fragen lasass euch
also was einfallen und haut rein macht
es schnell wahrscheinlich nur 24 Stunden
gibt es Zeit oder 48 Stunden diese
Fragen hochzuladen am besten als Video
in den Kommentaren wird's schwierig weil
es so viele sind und wir wenig Zeit
haben also haut rein